l'étang de 50 ans la plupart c'est un
rêve qui devient réalité
vingt membres du conseil des jeunes de
la ville de coprim nietzsche et en
république tchèque ont été accueillis
par leurs homologues trappistes de ville
jumelle rassembler autour du programme
erasmus plus c'est un programme
d'échangé européen erasmus plus en le
premier temps à nos jeunes à nos jeunes
de trappes sont partis en république
tchèque un co-prévenu chez pendant une
semaine
le deuxième temps pour le coup là c'est
nous qui recevront directement les
chèques chez nous attrape et le
troisième temps là c'est un peu
particulier donc nos jeunes trappistes
repartiront directement à co-prévenus
che en présence également de polonais
voilà pour impulser la création d'un
nouveau conseil des jeunes
semaine chargée pour les adolescents
visite du château de versailles ou
encore du sénat
mais aujourd'hui c'est la mairie de
crainte qu'ils découvrent l'engagement
dans un conseil de jeunes c'est une
démarche humaine s'est pas seulement une
démarche des philosophies culturel c'est
avoir envie de ne pas s'occuper que de
soi et de s'occuper aussi des autres de
sa ville mais aussi de te de ses
camarades des lycées et nos élèves un
échange de valeur mais aussi l' envie de
partager sa culture même si ici
communication grimm avec traduction est
là pour nous c'est juste que c'était
tchèque et nous on est français mais on
échange nos projets tels que je laisse
ko chic sm j'ai toujours voulu venir en
france et voir paris alors c'est une
très bonne occasion d'être là et de se
faire des amis en plus il y en a qui
parlent anglais mais la plupart du temps
mais c'est pas des échanges avec la
ville de coprim nietzsche et existe
depuis les années 70 mais c'est une
première pour le conseil des jeunes qui
préparent déjà leur deuxième voyage